this was a very different outbreak the
deadly Ebola virus devastating
communities in Africa now a drug used to
save lives over there is bringing hope
to Kovach patients over here this is
probably the biggest step forward in the
treatment of corona virus since the
crisis began these are very early steps
but we're determined to support the
science and back the projects that show
promise remedy severe is a
broad-spectrum antiviral drug it was
originally produced as a treatment for
hepatitis C but trials in the United
States have found it to be effective in
destroying a part of the corona virus to
stop it reproducing at a shortened
recovery time in some patients by up to
four days the drug has been fast-tracked
for use in America where it's been
compared to the breakthrough drugs used
to treat HIV it's the first step in what
we project will be better and better
drugs coming along either alone or in
combination drugs of this type and drugs
addressing other targets of the virus so
it's good news but I was very serious
when I said this is not the total answer
by any means but it's a very important
first step while the search for the
vaccine continues remedy severe is the
closest thing doctors have to a cure or
treatment of the disease
very few drugs for very few diseases
have a really dramatic benefits and when
we look back at HIV we found that even
though individual drugs worked quite
well the real way to make a big
difference was using combinations of
drugs and my view is that it's likely
that combinations of drugs will prove to
be most beneficial but we can't throw
our hands up and say this is the end of
the road clinical trials are continuing
here the International evidence seems to
convinced the government to make em
disappear the first medicine approved
for coronavirus patients in Britain but
only a few selected patients will be
given the drug the government won't say
how many or how soon Matt Hancock is
clearly very excited about this
development but we need to temper our
expectations
that's because REM de Sevilla is an
extremely short supply its producer
Gilead Sciences said it was increasing
the global supply but it expected
availability to be extremely limited for
the next few months there are many drugs
being trialed and tested but it looks
like REM de severe is the one that
offers the best hope until a vaccine is
found it may be the only choice Joshy
Sky News